Anderson.
24 hours after the
polls closed on the West Coast,
we still have, as we did
two years
ago, uncertainty
about two very important states
in American politics, including Arizona.
And Nevada.
So you just heard from Gary
and from Kyung,
let's start in Arizona, where Kyung is,
as she noted,
the last time votes were reported,
Mark Kelly's lead increase.
The key is to watch
the next batch of votes,
the one after that,
if you remember the dynamics in 20, 20.
It was Joe Biden's lead
that kept shrinking.
He won the state of the end,
but his lead was shrinking
as the ballots come in.
So the key is
what happens as we go forward.
And David laid out the percentages.
In Nevada,
we have the percentages for
Arizona as well.
So we have to watch this play out.
A vital state, obviously a vital race.
A Democratic incumbent
facing a challenger from a Trump
endorsed Republican.
They're critical to the 50
ballot 50 50 balance
we currently have in the Senate.
Where will it end up?
And then quickly in Nevada
this is where Gary is.
He's in Clark County.
It's 75%.
74% of the state vote.
And the question is,
can Cortez Masto
improve that percentage
as more and more votes come in?
That's what she needs to overcome.
One other key question
there is can she turn Washoe?
Washoe County
here, where Reno is,
and then the rural areas to the north.
That's a swing county,
usually the color of this county in
the end can determine who wins the state.
Laxalt with a slight
lead there right now.
Again, more votes to be counted.
I just want to come to this other map
just very quickly
to get to the question here,
which is why do these races matter?
Well, of course,
they matter
to the citizens of Arizona and Nevada.
They also matter to
the dynamics here in Washington.
Who controls the United States Senate?
This is a runoff in Georgia.
We know that now on December six.
The question is
if Senator Kelly can keep his lead here
and Senator Laxalt can keep
that lead here.
Neither of these are guaranteed,
by the way, as you heard
both correspondents,
tens of thousands of votes
still to be counted,
but there's no consequential,
because if that happened,
if this those two races stayed the same,
then guess what?
Republicans have 50 Democrats at 49.
And once again,
the Georgia
runoff would determine the control
the United States Senate
if Democrats would get back to 50
where they are now.
The vice president breaks the tie.
Republicans get to 51.
So any change in those races affects
whether or not this Georgia
runoff in December is decisive Anderson.
And we're going to have to wait
listening to Kyung and Gary
for a while to get that.
And just quickly,
I just want to come over.
You mentioned the House totals
at the top of the race.
I just want to show you the map
is it fills it looks like a lot of red,
but Republicans are not
at the finish line.
Republicans thought by now,
they thought by this time last night,
we would be saying
there will be a Republican majority
in the House of Representatives.
Here we are Wednesday night.
11 07 in the East.
Republicans are called there.
We have call 209.
So they are now nine House seats
short of 218.
The magic number for majority Democrats.
20 seats behind them right now at one 89.
Let's look where they're ahead.
This is really interesting
Republicans are ahead right now
in enough seats
enough seats
if nothing change to get a majority.
But look how narrow a majority
it would be if it stopped right now
it's not going to stop right now.
Some of these races will take days.
Some could take longer than that
to count.
But you just get the expectation
from looking at those numbers
where they stand right now
that, yes, the probability is Republicans
get to a majority.
It's also likely
that's going to be a very narrow
majority.
Well, one last point,
Anderson, before I come back.
Not enough
attention, in my view, has been paid
to this
Democratic governor
gets a new Democratic governor
in Pennsylvania,
Democratic governor reelected
in Michigan,
Democratic governor
reelected in Wisconsin,
reelected in Minnesota.
We talk a lot about the battleground
states out here.
They matter
who will win the governorship in Nevada,
who will win the governorship in Arizona.
These states right here.
A long time ago,
we used to call it the blue wall
they're incredibly important.
That was a little messy.
Let me do it one more time.
You come up here right in there. Yes.
The governor of Ohio was reelected,
but the Democrats held
Pennsylvania, held Michigan and held
Wisconsin in these governor's races
and under,
I think, underappreciated story
for the Democratic Party
in these midterm results.